greetings podcast villas uncle Joey here
the Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by you ready my boogie
dot AG let me talk to you about
something it's football season guys it's
baseball playoff time World Series will
be in two weeks all the guys are walking
around scratching your head looking at
pick a winner but let me tell you
something where your betting is is just
as important as who you betting on you
got a winner that's why I always tell
people if you got a winner go to my
bookie got a G my bookie dot AG has been
in business for years and their rep is
rock solid solid like the Rock of
Gibraltar they do want to percent cash
bonuses so off the bat you're making
money doing nothing here's what I'm
gonna do for you right join today and my
bookie will match your deposit with up
to $100 a hundred percent bonus of your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
Joey would you just say $1,000 okay
they'll match your deposit with an up to
a hundred percent bonus of your first
deposit so use promo code Church to
activate the offer go to my bookie AG
today and use promo code Church you play
you win you get paid [ __ ] number two
you want to look good in your underwear
and be comfortable right but the perfect
balance is hard to find don't sacrifice
style or comfort check out me on these
calm right now and find the best pair
underwear in the world comfortable
lights that I mean listen I've been
using like my the first ones I got with
the sabotage ones whatever the [ __ ]
camouflage ones with my fat ass and my
ball sack and [ __ ] first off the first
net goes them with my underwear as they
start ripping none of them and that with
me and these you know why tough go to me
on these calm right now this one wanna
do for you right I'm gonna get you 20%
off free shipping and their hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee and get
the best and softest underwear you'll
ever own go to me on these calm slash
Joey again that's me on these calm
/ Joey again there's a limited time
offer so don't wait for dick go to me on
these calm right now kick this
[ __ ] mealy
you
kidding me or what a little old-school
Cinderella fee you [ __ ] it's
Wednesday October 4th
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
my one of my best friends in life called
me telling informed me that his grandma
died and to be honest for you guys she's
the closest thing I've ever had to a
grandma so I woke up this morning I saw
the missed call and you know when you're
looking at missed call and you look at
what time it came in and you know it's
not good because you know what time
people usually call me he calls me an
839 her friend to call me at 6:15 I knew
it was her and I remember I did a bunch
of I knew she was dead they put her in
our I'll old folks home about three
months ago and they have you know she
was just she's 90 something you know and
she was kind of crazy and [ __ ] and
that's what I loved about her but uh
yeah my condolences to his family and I
felt like [ __ ] all day because you know
I love you guys my shouldn't be doing a
podcast with you I should be in New York
with George at his house and it's funny
because somebody gave me a bottle of
that ass water that [ __ ] what's that
champagne that all these [ __ ]
Gentiles oh I'm pairing [ __ ] dick you
ever drank that [ __ ] now I'm not like
him ten percent it's a psych dick
I like cheap champagne did the apple
juice in it whatever the [ __ ] you know
it's but it's is really anything in the
world but they took me in I knew George
since my sophomore going into signing
George before my mother died and he was
foreclosed side bark and I was from
North Bergen and we kept in touch on the
phone and then he started dating a girl
I knew in North Bergen he would give her
a little stab wound from time to time
and I would communicate to him through
her and then I lost contact with him for
like a year or two and then we
reconnected in 84 I got arrested in
Bergen County he bailed me out and he
told me I could stay with his parents or
his mom his grandma Dillard running with
Terrace where Jim Norton didn't Jimmy
Florentine
oh wow he's full of and I stayed with
them for six months the first time and
they
was it slowed me down a little bit they
never made me feel bad about living
there you know I always worked
I always fixed my bed in the morning I
gave them money I gave grandma money for
bingo that was my deal to give her 40
bucks for bingo once a week plus rent
she'd cook for me you know it was a
great relationship they took care of me
like one of their own there's something
special about grandmas not honor she was
always tight and just a sense of humor
she hated [ __ ] Cuba
she said Cuba was a [ __ ] death trap
that it was the death was a sin the
reason why the country was a piece of
[ __ ] now because they had a good time
there for a long time but that was the
borderline for the slaves so they put a
[ __ ] voodoo on the country then
offend you at all no I don't give a [ __ ]
when people talk she's my friend when I
give a [ __ ] you know and then I left an
85 I always kept in touch from as a
matter of fact George came out to
Colorado in 87 lived with me till I got
arrested for the kidnapping he saved me
for a little while came out for the
court case for me to get sentenced 91
when I got divorced and I was down and
out I were back and stayed with him he
was junked up and Grandma as bad as I
was feeling in those days that was the
first time I was away from my daughter
and that was the first time I had been
away from Boulder and I'll tell you
being North Bergen was great and doing
comedy for the first couple that was my
second year Tommy when I moved back with
George in Jersey I drove a limo and I
went back to New York and I uh
I did comedy I was going to do comedy at
night for [ __ ] three minutes just to
get abused I mean I was just getting
abused guys so right now if you [ __ ]
getting abused you're doing comedy or
you're starting law school or you're
doing anything and you just started and
you feel like you getting abused think
of me when you get in the buttes I got
it was an abusing guys it was abuse you
know that's why whenever I see comics
and they young I try to give my hog a
separate nice because I know what the
[ __ ] they going through but when all
that going on and the abuse of my
ex-wife and not talking to my child and
all this [ __ ]
grandma how was who kept me together and
I'm not saying she wasn't it wasn't
amazing but
it wasn't probably anything too big
right it was like maybe a sandwich
little thing she talked to me at night I
had one shirt
I was snorting so much coke in those
days I had one [ __ ] white collared
shirt so I would take it off wash it
every night and she would iron it for me
and I worried the next morning that
[ __ ] shirt was gray
you couldn't bleach it anymore it was so
[ __ ] old did you have to ask and iron
it I'm sure he just did it yesterday I
just give him money for bingo and stuff
you know but before all that happened
like April of 85 I was living with them
and I was working for this [ __ ] dude
like I had no jobs I had nothing going
on and I was just picking up day labor
is that what you call it daily yeah so I
was working for this guy
his name was John he was a real [ __ ]
prick he abused me too
this is 84 this was before probably I'm
taking you back like eight years this
guy was a [ __ ] scumbag so he would
tell me to meet him at 7:00 at the diner
okay
I would go up there I would eat and then
he wouldn't pay for breakfast and then
he would sit there till 8:30 you know
and then he would only pay me from nine
o'clock on he wouldn't pay me for
windshield time you know we clocked out
at 3:00 he would pay me two three even
if it took two hours to get home the guy
was just a scumbag and I needed the
[ __ ] work like I needed the [ __ ]
work and it wasn't bad it was four days
a week
I helped him carry wood much wet
something small like the way yeah little
things yeah a little huge difference he
would he would not give me a check he
would say for God'll on Friday I was
tapped out I had to pay rent you know I
had to pay grandma money for [ __ ]
bingo and this [ __ ] guy would tell me
he had no check on his [ __ ] he was a
real piece of [ __ ] so I knew where he
lived in one Friday one Thursday night
this [ __ ] douchebag tells me he's
going away for the weekend and that was
the weekend he ran away without paying
so I went to listen he gave you t-shirts
to wear on his jobs if he didn't wear
the t-shirts he'd find your $10 if your
t-shirt wasn't washed like just dumb
[ __ ] he was just a scumbag so I said
[ __ ] this
[ __ ] how long did it make you to
take you to make that decision to rob
and like he tells you he's gonna be busy
but you knew you know me you know me
that's why I love you that's he's
demanding like you saying like he's
gonna be gone for the week you know know
what I went to meet him that morning he
said I'll meet you Thursday morning at
the fine dining so I to get like a cab
to drive me to this [ __ ] diner and
then he's not there oh I eat breakfast
of my last 20 now I got a walk halfway
[ __ ] home because I don't have all
the money and then call a cab
they look like six miles and call a cab
oh no so now I'm [ __ ] furious
I got no dough no prospects I go you
know I'm doing tomorrow morning getting
up I'm going over this [ __ ] outfit I
went over to his [ __ ] house I had
never drank Dom Perignon and I do about
down pairing yeah cuz one time my
buddies robbed uh a truck like they had
like a [ __ ] delivery truck I don't
know what they robbed they robbed
something and they gave me like three
bottles and I gave him away I didn't
know I sold two of them to a liquor
store but wasn't they giving a box right
there in a box yeah I think so so yeah
it was in a box how do you sell it to a
liquor store listen I got to do with
these what do you sell them for 129 I'll
give it to you for 60 got to love me and
give me 130 for the whole way this is 60
I'm sorry him is 65 make that bro people
buy anything you walk into any liquor
store with a case that's closed and they
open it in front and you tell them I'll
give you a hold fail on this I'll give
you 50 percent oh I still get the cash
out of the back cuz that's what people
do that that's a case of booze they sell
that they buy the bottle Western
wholesale they buy for half we have to
find someone where the owner is running
the cash or discuss 2017 they're all
[ __ ] kinky [ __ ] you have to assume
that going and that's not one you
deliver the speech to them you have to
assume like they're on the other side
they know what [ __ ] time is going in
okay so you have this the dump hang on
so I know no I go to the guy's house
right I can't get in there I gotta be
creative so I just bust through a
[ __ ] window like a superhero
I go and I climb in there I got all the
time in the world
he even took the dog with him that dump
oh I got all the time in the world and I
just went through his [ __ ] house I
think I made eggs you know when I would
burglarize here and I knew you weren't
coming back I always make some type of
sandwich I always hear that on the news
he in your toriel is something now you
can't do that because they'll get you
DNA from the beat so [ __ ] I found like
a couple yards takes couple hundred
dollars I found a little weed and he had
like his those anniversary things when
people give you for anniversaries um you
know a bunch of bottles of Dom Perignon
I put that would bother him more in the
cash I took every bottle it's Bob what
[ __ ] had you know like thirteen
bottles a big doll in the box I took I
took them too long I knew I dumped every
[ __ ] bottle I kept one for me just to
see what all the [ __ ] was about and
me grandma George drank that carafe it
wasn't even a regular bottle it was a
carafe raft
oh my god they're even more expensive
they like to something back then back
then there were even more expensive
their way to doing our bottle so me
George and grandma got in that living
room oh and we drank the whole
[ __ ] bottle of Dom Perignon
good grandma out drink you guys she was
having a great time we play music just
meet her and grandma we danced and then
about ten o'clock oh this is all
unplanned I took the money I robbed
I took George Graham on me to pick a
Lisa Moe for lobster [ __ ] fraud
Diablo and it was just magne listen she
would still bring that night up in 1993
now she wouldn't bring it up because she
didn't remember it but she always told
me that was one of the best nights I
have had she got home from bingo we got
a tip see his [ __ ] and then we took a
full lobster at the [ __ ] piccoli
similar Fort Lee New Jersey are you
kidding me so that's all I kept thinking
about today that memory that night I saw
it vividly about us dancing in the
living room and us giggling and I would
go outside and smoke pot and I would
committed to go look at you because
that's just she recalled marijuana geeks
you always go you I say e so well like
what how did you explain to her about
the champagne and the dinner
a friend gave with them and I work for
the money yeah I've explained nothing
the least you say the [ __ ] better it
is in your life and I gotta tell you
something people you guys come up to me
after shows some people give me hugs and
then some people look me in the eye and
go hey uh thank you for helping me guess
what guys were even by you know what
guys just let me tell this story I got
happy like this is what I was waiting
for all day this [ __ ] podcast of that
because I had so much the last couple
days have just been laughs everybody the
last two months and really been an
emotional toll for everybody if you have
any empathy at all in your [ __ ] body
you know yeah what was first Houston
yeah did Florida and you know [ __ ]
Cuba for two weeks I couldn't get ahold
of my sister you know it's just been a
[ __ ] nightmare Anka and Lyndsey got
the cancer then [ __ ] you know it
they're happening so often now that we
forget about them forget abut like you
think someone brought it up the other
day or like when the Hurricanes were
happening this Flint really still not
have water does the Flint really still
not have water they don't give a [ __ ]
that's so listen Monday morning when I
looked at that a Las Vegas thing yeah I
go Paulo rigo's [ __ ] because this is
gonna Trump oh no Rica this is bigger
than Puerto Rico fifty something people
dying and I don't know how many people
get injured disadvantage for Torito so
there you go the the the laser know what
they call it the I here's an over Puerto
Rican oh right it just not it's over Las
Vegas I mean it's Wednesday night if we
turn on CNN there's still this store Las
Vegas I mean there's gonna be a huge
fight there this weekend yeah by
tomorrow
everybody starts to fly in Friday they
really fly in and [ __ ] I don't know
what that I would the Mandalay Bay is
gonna do like they might have to close
off that entire floor I would bet I
wouldn't even want to stay at the
Mandalay Bay right now at this point I
love that hotel so itself I love that
hotel but the last couple of times I've
stayed there it hasn't been to Kosh it
really hasn't been to coach
that's what they used to have the fights
right yeah yeah yeah yeah it hasn't been
too kosher especially you go down after
midnight that's always when I'm down
especially realer than after one or two
it's a little on the scary side down
there you can see that there's a lot of
people look in the [ __ ] you know I
bought you looking to get some money
it's a scary situation I've been in
those places and it's scary you were
talking about before about paying
attention and not like the thing that
scares me the most now is just the cars
as terrible as it sounds like obviously
guns terrible but it happened in
Edmonton like the night before Vegas I
got to get you all guys I got explained
Vegas they love you very much if you
listen to this show and if you don't
listen to this show we know anything
about me
I love [ __ ] up dude but I got a lot of
heart and and one thing about me is all
those years as a young kid in Union City
and my mother had that bar sois was the
unofficial lookout do you know what that
meant that meant that whenever I went to
the movies okay I don't walk back
already I knew when I got three blocks
of my mother's ball to start looking
around for suspicious cause okay a guy
sitting in the car by himself a guy in
an unmarked car car you know two cop
cars together three cop cars together
having coffee that means something's
about to go down okay
and when your mom asked you when you got
something no I would say it to it huh oh
yeah okay something's going on at the
corner there's a cop car up there you
insane just so they had their heads up
you know when I was a kid I'm trying to
write this thing to sell a TV show the
cell about how a my mom came from Cuba
and then she [ __ ] you know Mel Puerto
Rican girl and they got into bookmaking
together and then my mom went back but
she was out doing since there was two
girls taking numbers they were out doing
the big booking around their
neighborhood so the guy who was taking
their action gave my mother and the
Puerto Rican euro a spot spot so that's
how my mom got
the numbers then she met my dad and
[ __ ] my dad financed her own bank and
her own another guy started a bank and
my mother never stopped with the number
since that the beautiful part of this is
that when I was born and all that I was
born into that so sometimes on Saturdays
my mom will go up to the Bronx to the
bank and I didn't like it at first but
then every time I went I would get 40 or
50 bucks when you're five and six and
somebody gives you 40 [ __ ] bucks and
a doll is three dollars I tell a lot of
money indeed but they treat you as a
child like that what did you know what
it wasn't you all I knew exactly when I
was five six seven you know I have Julio
Rodriguez calling here he's my cousin
he's the digital teacher in Lyndhurst he
owns anaconda jiu-jitsu in Lyndhurst his
younger brother Geo who's dead now God
rest his soul and me we must have been
eight behind and every Saturday when I
got out I kept mumbling I've thrown on a
Catholic school it started before I got
thrown on a Catholic school so I would
go out on Friday nights I would go to
the movies on Friday and Saturday
morning I'd have to meet those guys I
was like either nine and I'd have to
meet those dudes to go over the city and
me and Gil would run we would go for
coffee we'd go for bonds but then after
12 me and Gil were basically runners
where we picked up different numbers
from different banks around the area
within a 5 or 6 block distance that's
what we did we were runners so when
you're running that's why they pay you
to keep your [ __ ] eyes only keep your
eyes on that's it using something as a
hotter place you [ __ ] say it well
they would they give you any money if
you caught something no they would pay
me for the day they would give me 50
[ __ ] dollars for the daily sandwiches
ok and light firecrackers and hang out
on the corner with a bunch of other
[ __ ] dirty kids I was even going to
ask you about this tonight like I feel
like now there's a big difference
between being a kid and being an adult I
think there's a it's a very big jump
back then like I came in like now that
would be stress like
I can't imagine being five or six and
being a runner in New York City Michael
Jackson Michael Jackson's biggest
complaint was they didn't have a
childhood right there's a lot of times I
sit here and I don't think I had a lot
of childhood it doesn't sound like why I
always went to people older than me I
never hung out with kids my age I always
hung up with people older than me well
that was ten I don't know were 13 year
olds yeah 13 I think I was 16 year olds
I didn't like it because I was used I
was always used up being around older
people you know I didn't go to any
daycare I don't remember going they take
care I do remember being in kindergarten
I remember be in the first grade second
grade and all that stuff if I wasn't at
school I was at home and when he didn't
they talk about when you're home they
talk about your school and all that [ __ ]
but when they're talking amongst
themselves and they're on the phone
they're talking about their business
which was numbers right I just highly
IIIi think back I think about the
stories you tell and I try to think back
if if like I remember certain things but
I don't even know and I notice myself
whenever I deal with kids now it's not
it's not a fake but there's a person you
put on you're trying to be happy
try to do this and that and I can't
imagine like as I got older my dad would
talk about he liked certain things with
his work or something but as a kid like
I think even if I had kids I would make
an effort to not let them see that stuff
let's say I was hooked my mom's boss
okay my mom called me over for some I
should give me a kiss and we talked
about something I gotta be watching
Mickey Mouse or Little Rascals I was a
big TV guy as a kid you learn the
language when you're talking about any
of that [ __ ] when you watching that my
mom will come over and talk to me and
then she would give me like a lesson for
the day
ain't no like hey if anybody comes to
you and tries to give you candy tell him
to go [ __ ] himself
you know if somebody opens up the door
and tells you getting a car time to go
[ __ ] themselves you know my mom was one
of those people always that was always
getting a tidbit she'd always take me
outside where he said her [ __ ] guy's
a piece of [ __ ]
chocolate [ __ ] guy you know there was
always something with her she was very
blunt and a boy what do you mean I got
would try to argue when she couldn't
even [ __ ] hog because he's a piece of
[ __ ] he's a piece of [ __ ] don't talk to
him if he comes up to you kick him in
the leg real [ __ ] hard and run away
you know like my mom always had a piece
of tidbit no matter what we were doing
there was always a lesson you know there
was always a lesson somewhere for me
growing up I liked hanging out with
adults I like that that feeling it felt
like I had something over kids when I
was hanging out with them cool like I
was that I felt cool not you buddy
liked it I always felt so insecure about
my being an immigrant I always felt so
insecure about not being smart you know
like whatever okay so that was my hook
that I knew about the world
no that was my hook that I knew about
the world and what was really going on
the kids I hung out with in Manhattan
growing up were really nice kids like
you now I go up 248 Street and I met my
match these kids all raised like me
because they're poor that bent ow he was
still there where you know you just you
didn't these kids didn't go to Yankee
games these kids didn't go to met games
like me if you took one of those kids at
the age of six to a Met game they would
kill feed or for the rest of their lives
dip kill for you because you're
providing that dream that their parents
can't do you know himself it was a
law-and-order on with uh I think it's
Mike on pareo if somebody was popular
that he plays a coach at like one of
those boys houses you know like a the
boys club in Manhattan and he's telling
them all that he's gonna build the house
up in the mountains and they're gonna
have shooting ranges and this and that
horses and the when you're a kid that's
a [ __ ] and you're in that I thought
you grew up in that type of element a
hundred and forty like that I always
talk about the sedan yells let's so
let's just focus on the sedan yells okay
I love the sedan Aeolus they had a
brother named Ricky and they've had a
brother named Nelson
but beside that there was nine of them
and they had an older sister named nine
kids yeah look up riders of the Purple
Sage her name was Nancy said Danielle
Wikipedia and see the list of background
singers over here she said Danielle was
on two albums she was a hot Porter we
can check up on 148th Street now when I
grew up with Ricky and Nelson I was a
band writers are the purpose here the
writers are the new riders of the Purple
Sage okay they were like a spinoff I
don't know what like huh like a Bob
Dylan ish type [ __ ] hippie-ish you know
this is 1970 1969 1968 when I'm running
with these kids
so now Leonel since Danielle Ricky said
Danielle you know I can't remember the
rest of the other kids there was a
Jewish kid that his parents owned
something on the block like a night
store or something okay he was a tough
kid there was a black kid in that
neighborhood that ran with us I don't
remember his name
and there was like a blonde head Irish
kid that was tough and him and Nelson
would fight all the time and Nelson was
the oldest out of all of us so if I'm
hanging out with these kids at 6
Nelson's 10 and this other kid this
Irish kid was about eight and he would
[ __ ] him and Nelson would beat
themselves up two or three times a week
where I lived on 88th Street this was
not nobody fought on that block right
yeah no you know one of them blocking me
and I got be that blase if I Rudy this
Haitian kid we called him something what
it really did you ruination I forget
what the [ __ ] we called them Rudy the
Haitian really some of them weren't that
unique heat me and Rudy were good
friends but we used to fistfight
sometime that time and one day [ __ ]
we got into a fight and his father held
me while Rudy punched me in the stomach
and busted my lip hope that the buck in
the
this had to be before this was before
Catholic school Oh Mike this is what led
my mother these were all the decisions
that led my mother in the third grade to
put me in calculus school and that was
probably the father held you the father
held my arms outside where the kid hit
me saying the father took me upstairs
told my threaten my mother my mother
chased him with a knife and then the
cops came and we had to move out of
there by two months later oh my god you
had to move we had hope I need a victus
there in a Vectis they just said it's
better if you guys start looking for a
different place know that Jesus Christ
but my point is know no more about no
Ron is a problem st. Louis yeah you
can't find it my point is that I was
raised doing that at an early age
you know I guess at the end Timmy
listens to this podcast about true me
when you got a caller Roger if you were
driving he didn't want to hear a word
out of your [ __ ] mom here do i if you
[ __ ] drive and don't say a [ __ ]
word alright just drive the [ __ ] car
we all want to hear a long story we
don't want you smoking don't wait don't
know just drive the [ __ ] car we'll
fill you when we get there you are
pretty specific when I'm driving I don't
like people [ __ ] around when you're
outside you see how I am when I'm I pay
attention put your head up I never like
this [ __ ] phone and how people look
at that [ __ ] phone it drives me crazy
and you made a good point before the
podcast started you know what I'm scared
of cars too I'm [ __ ] petrified of
cars all these busy streets
c-dawg the world changes again not only
the world changed America changed again
on Monday and how people think and
people like me [ __ ] this scares me
Monday I was not all there again the
podcast saved me that night with Nick in
the [ __ ] pizza and those [ __ ] buns
he brought with blue cheese in them
Jesus Christ but I was having a tough
day Monday and I always feel like I'm
not an empathetic person but I [ __ ]
am because it affects me it affected me
Monday
like I didn't want to know dick yeah I
had a good time here but even yesterday
it affected me I am trying to watch at
least about this as I can yeah me too
and the thing about being empathetic
like you have to have empathy for the
people who have these terrible things
happen to them but at a certain point if
you let all of this stuff in like that's
why people are getting depression from
social media like you can't you just
can't emotion is that a gift [ __ ]
house turn on my wife any day
yeah I can feel it I can feel it and
I'll tell you why because especially
Facebook yeah Facebook is just it's
become a psychotherapist people just go
there and pull [ __ ] up and then they
start into Wars
I've never seen anything like that yeah
I've never seen what gets posted on
there I never thought that I would come
to the day like when you go in all your
years did you think there was gonna be a
medical marijuana store everything you
were gonna walk into it's the same thing
I thought all that stuff was for jollies
for us to have a good time you know
that's what I thought it was for us to
crack jokes and for us to say [ __ ]
they're throwing people off now the
animal people off now they're banning
people they get pissed at people it's
become something different you know it
really has become something different I
think it's time to start a new [ __ ]
page for 18 and over we could put people
[ __ ] getting jerked off in the face
people getting shot
it's like will stop hip hop right with
you it's your page so you only show
three Chinese guys getting hit in the
head with hammers so be it if you want
to show three black guys getting shot
cuz you into that so beat if you want to
show three white guys go whatever the
[ __ ] you want but anyway not to take
away from anything you in the other way
ya wanna take away from what's going on
here I will tell you one thing ladies
and gentlemen and after I say this to
you you know my stance on all the
[ __ ] and everything but I will tell
you this
like I said I just know like I hadn't
watch world news tonight the last
tonight I did that for a [ __ ] reason
cuz I don't want to take that that's my
favorite show
at 6:30 if you call me you're not gonna
get home the phone is plugged in in a
complete different room I really don't
care who calls when I'm watching the
world news tonight I don't [ __ ] around
and there was a time when Diane Sawyer
was I I was gonna say even without Diane
there if you called my house that's what
I would pick up the phone and tell you
to go [ __ ] your mother and hang up on
you how dare you call me during Diane
Sawyer anyway I will tell you one thing
Lee that I feel and if something is not
right you guys forget I'm a criminal
before I got into this you guys forget
that I had urges of killing three people
in my life and had dreams about it and
would [ __ ] fantasize about it without
medication and without [ __ ] I would
just sit there and salivate it was like
coming when I was 21 and I was thinking
at killing one it was like coming every
night same myself you know walked down
the street with tiptoeing and coming up
to him and shooting him in the leg and
watch them drop to one leg and then
shooting them in the back and he
fantasized the whole watch oh my god oh
my god many at times many at times I
fantasized it and then after that what I
do who I want to kill there was somebody
else I want to go after and that was a
fantasy of like three years and then it
took me what it took me for ten or
fifteen years the fantasy of me killing
my ex-wife and her [ __ ] husband were
there in my heart I can't lie to nobody
you want me to tell you they didn't
exist sure they did doesn't matter they
[ __ ] did doesn't all that fantasizing
about angry things make you angry like
were you in angrier person absolutely
absolutely
abso-fucking-lutely it makes you an
angry person and you know you got now
you got a few cocaine in there
ah because all these periods I'm telling
you about when I fantasize killing
people
cocaine was [ __ ] in there like got
like a [ __ ] gunpowder you know I'm
saying so let's add that to the mix
there was no antidepressants or no
[ __ ] like this I was putting cocaine
into my body so I had thousands of
fantasies guys cuz you want me to lie to
you and tell you I'm not that type of
person and I had thousands of fantasies
you know when you lose something as
important as a parent or something like
there's something that that's important
to you it can be a [ __ ] dog week it
could be a dog that pushes you over the
top it could be a girl that you saw
getting hit by a car
you don't know how are your body and
your mind is gonna react to this [ __ ]
but for me on a personal level I could
tell you one thing that when I lost my
mother within three or four years I had
the hatred of [ __ ] Satan in my heart
which meant if I was sitting down I saw
you crossing the street Lee I would
cheer for a car to hit you in the
[ __ ] leg and I didn't even know who
you are but when you take away religion
from a man and belief and a piece of
their soul they want everybody to suffer
how they're suffering it's a childish
way to think but that's how I thought at
that time after I saw what I was doing
and my behavior and how I was acting
then I shifted it over the years and now
I won't kill nobody
no I just want to go home and I want to
hang out with you and hug my daughter
and see the [ __ ] cats and finish this
game up or whatever this game is I'm 54
I don't know what the [ __ ] I got left I
did coke for 30 years there's got to be
a valve off the hook in there somewhere
but at least I'm honest with myself I'm
not that way you don't see me out
jumping up and down and gallivanting and
being somebody I'm not right you know so
again you know I think something went on
Vegas I don't think we're getting all
the real story are you guys have my
saying conspiracy theory don't even
[ __ ] say that you dumb [ __ ]
you know that's not what I believe but I
believe something else I don't know what
it is something isn't right and I don't
know what it is I'm a criminal yeah if
you go online there's 8 million
theater-going but
and the issue is if anything that's
saying like it's a government conspiracy
to kill its own citizens like in the
backpack back of my head I know that
it's a possibility but I don't I don't
want it to be like yeah and that's
another yeah I guess you can't live that
way and that's probably what a lot of
people are just getting mad about but I
don't want to live in an in a world
where some of that like America's doing
that I didn't say America week right
well yeah I'd say in America I'm looking
at it from just something doesn't seem
right
I don't know what is I can't put my
finger on it
you guys know me I just don't know what
it is
I'm not saying America Oh see I am but
some people are yeah I don't even know
what to think you know and I mean you
try to scroll on Facebook yeah kind of
sweet kind of a nice person and you see
totally different things and you leaked
this that you know my big thing is ok so
you read through the room you busted a
window right and you shot people for 10
minutes how many guns of the area at
least 30 I think right no yeah 18 19
then a couple handguns and [ __ ] you put
a peephole you put a camera in his
peephole
you put a cameras and his a room service
dish car in the car and he put a baby to
monitor in the living room so they could
he could watch walk he was also
supposedly taping himself now wait this
was my only question here you just shot
2,200 you know whatever
yeah I don't know how many rounds don't
don't you know please like it yeah Holly
Lowndes but I do know one thing at that
point
wouldn't you shoot it out with the
[ __ ] cops he thinks I will just keep
going out the window or something cuz
you did stop I see yeah you just stop
the 10:15 and shot himself I don't
understand this so that those I have
three or four knows I don't want to turn
the podcast right into something it
isn't but uh again my [ __ ] hearts and
prayers go out to these victims and I
hope that we find the Lansing you know
and then just from being at the coffee
shop today I heard people next to me it
was two nice women and they were talking
about gun advocacy and all this [ __ ] and
guess what [ __ ] if you want
that concert Sunday Lee and you lived
right you made it back to your house and
your hug ball and you sat down he said
joy I'm taking a week off but what are
you gonna do next
you're thinking about buying a gun okay
that's not ever gonna happen to you
again and you never start thinking about
Paul and you just start thinking about
your mother you gonna start thinking
about deke syat right and how many
things they go to and you start thinking
about this [ __ ] this changes you guess
what whether it's the next day or within
60 days you're gonna buy a pistol
because you never gonna want to be put
in that position again I wonder how many
applications were filed for guns the
last two days probably a lot but that's
and what we've talked I think we talked
about this last year or something around
list our something something happened
and guns have always scared me and I
know people have a lot of emotional
attachment to their guns for reasons for
hunting for reasons just failing
whatever their reasons are well I'll
tell you what if one day you and Paul
are walking down the [ __ ] Street
right and two kids come up to you and
they put a gun to your neck and they
take your wallet huh and the kid takes
ball this ball was wallet right and
before he leaves he smacks her in the
face and she goes down a glasses break
right let me ask you something how are
you gonna feel as an America
you know how are you gonna feel as a
human being I'm terrible okay
awful but why did it why can this guy
for $200 buy something that turns his
gun into an automatic well they know
that it's just time I said I forgot
about that guy okay the next step
easy smack balla balla goes down right
okay you're gonna go home you're gonna
go through a bunch of emotions and so is
Paul right one of the motions you're
gonna go through is maybe I should go
back to Krav Maga Yeah right because
[ __ ] Maga guys could disarm a
[ __ ]
you know you what my point is is you
never want it to happen again no never
want it to happen again
no you have to deal with Paul you know
Paul is a sweet girl you got kicked in
the stomach it ain't no big deal you
wrestled in high school you [ __ ] around
with us someone get cake they punch at
the Comedy Store from time to time T or
something Paul is not used to getting
kicked neither is my wife neither are
the wives of people listening to this
podcast right now the men listen to this
podcast so my point is if this happened
to you within how many days do you think
you're gonna figure out your next move
from protection immediately okay
is it a karate class is it a jiu-jitsu
class is it a boxing class is it a
technically it's a tactical class where
you learn how to fire weapons and will
you probably buy a weapon for the next
time as much as you hate a gun because
you hate a gun because you have no
knowledge of a gun and they scare you
once you get knowledge of a gun and what
a gun could do but these are the people
I go you know Deathwish what does
Deathwish about a guy and they robbed
his [ __ ] house they raped his wife
and his daughter becomes a Momo he goes
to Arizona to stay with her to build the
project and while he's down there the
dude takes him to shoot and he knows
he's heartbroken on the way back he
throws a piece of this luggage and he
goes I put a little something there for
you for when you get back to New York
right Charles Bronson gets back to New
York opens up that [ __ ] suitcase and
looks in that goddamn thing that's a
[ __ ] piece and a half
and he started shooting people to lights
later you understand me and he was an
engineer no he's an architect Paul
Kersey he was an architect in that movie
but he's just how many [ __ ] movies
are surrounded around somebody get
killed and [ __ ] all of a sudden who's
this sort of taken leaning all of a
sudden he becomes [ __ ] Johnny Steele
and he gets weapons and lockers and he's
shooting people he was all he was
ex-seal whatever he was but no yeah I
mean it see those are a lot of movies
and I get that I get that urge but I
mean if you want a do you want to take
it to the next I mean people are gonna
get mad regardless of what you said
behalf of the people gonna get mad no no
I'm not listening I'm not saying that
it's a time to buy a gun it's not the
time everybody has their own it isn't
it's not the thing we sent everybody I
am NOT gonna sit in a room and argue
with somebody about guns because
everybody's different exactly yeah
everybody's different how automatic
thing yes you have to battle all that
stuff and give 30 years in possessions
automatic time you know guaranteed time
whatever it's called done yeah whatever
it's plush stuff yeah you they catch you
it's automatic 25 years no plea bargain
no nothing
you know you spending those sentences
with a $50,000 fine
whatever I don't [ __ ] know right I
don't know and while they said he had
like 30 he had 30 guns right 30 guns
so mate like for you all together 19 or
something there and 20 something at the
house I'll flip flopped who all was 40
[ __ ] handguns listen we all know if
you got a heartbeat you could buy a gun
and I can record clean you could buy a
gun or you can pay somebody and give
them and nobody guns fees the same thing
no big [ __ ] deal there's always a way
to get a gun that's the sad thing in
American society you could always buy a
gun you can have four guns you have to
go to the register tuturro dirty just in
case [ __ ] goes down you gotta shoot a
[ __ ] and put a gun in his hand
you get out what what that you don't
think there's people who walk right what
is the thing isn't there you ever see
anything about that [ __ ] Jew in New
York that was shooting people
no but not the dude was listening to the
dog the other one that was Bernie
records right the first guy that who was
listening to the dog summer Sam Sam
Berkowitz okay which if I put a little
wig on you you look a little like him
maybe I am him summer stated he finds no
he's still alive I don't know one of
them and then you haven't the guy before
him gets did you ever see Bernard gets
the name sounds familiar but I can't
allow you to Bernard interview Bernard
gets
c180 Z I think one of those combinations
Tod I think that was the name of the guy
who did the [ __ ] [ __ ] in the city in
1977
why would a harmless guy like this
subway vigilante yes
what with you visualizing all this
[ __ ]
what on a roll one twenty minutes no no
but let's see if he's just that there's
got to be sure yummy final YouTube now
you know his name just put it this gotta
be like a two-minute one I just want you
to show him he says something that was
so [ __ ] up they said why'd you shoot
the other guys some cuz he was breathing
like he was [ __ ] because why do you
think the interview he tells you I've
been mugged four times that was one of
the worst times ever in New York City
that was one of the worst times ever in
New York City
well yeah well how long was he out there
for look he looked like Ari and he look
a lot but I guess if I had more bullets
I would have I would have shot them all
over again
look at this [ __ ] listen for this [ __ ]
this is what happens
look at re if you don't know about this
gonna burn hard gets on YouTube if I had
more bullets I would have shot them all
again and again look at this guy what's
he waiting 120
you gotta click around some okay them
all again and again you know my problem
was I ran out of bullets and I was gonna
I was gonna gal one of the guys eyes out
with my keys afterwards you know you you
can't understand this I know you can't
understand this that's fine
the reason the only reason I didn't do
it is because he changed his love
he achieves kill understand if you're
gonna I know they're gonna give you a
copy of the tape
probably okay of course they're gonna
force it on okay it's do I have to go
through do you want to hear one more
time what what oh my god he just didn't
give a [ __ ] he didn't give a [ __ ] but
his background was something crazy like
something that happened to him and yeah
it looks like he were here he had been
bullied a son you know these
[ __ ] okay he's crazy
there's another one you seem to be doing
alright here's another this is how
craziest guy got on the ground push too
tight
and they were taking care of it's all
very cold-bloodedness I'm just gonna
spend everyone I went back to the other
two to check on that
and the fellow who was standing up I was
sure it shot it was fine
[Music]
I want to give it a sense a lot - I went
I went to him the second time when I
looked at
you can't verify this because he was
probably out of it by then I shot him or
if he wasn't I don't know nicely you
seem to be doing alright here's another
huh oh my god there's wouldn't get
bullied and the guy just snaps antsy but
not gets death wish in real life this is
you know I'm basing what I'm having a
conversation are you about about things
I've seen you know there's been a
thousand movies made about it
were you ever in prison with someone who
just snapped right now at the prison one
of the scariest guys in there was a guy
called Spencer had one and his nemesis
was graveyard he was part of a leader of
a different little black group okay
antwuan Chicken Hawk had a bigger black
following and he had the kitchen so this
chicken hawk honking graveyard graveyard
and Chicken Hawk and Antwon Spencer
hands waters Chicken Hawk gotcha Spencer
hands one is Chicken Hawk gotcha and his
two lieutenants were asked a do from
Memphis who was [ __ ] hysterical and I
don't forget the other guy
Oh be from Buffalo and this guy was six
foot six big you know not muscular he
then when no mr. Olympia none but he
would pick you up through a [ __ ] neck
and he was in there for some assault and
Chicken Hawk was in there for
involuntary manslaughter but it was
really Murder two
let it down
and I became frozen you don't ask people
what they're in jail for glad became
friends well he was my boss in the
kitchen I hung out with him a lot and I
really liked him like he was some New
Orleans he was he had a gold tooth this
[ __ ] okay
had an ID and [ __ ] like floated and
the hotter he was the more the I would
float and the the packet would I've ever
talked about which this is classic [ __ ]
the pack every day the main crew at the
library was me Chicken Hawk and the guy
from Buffalo who killed his wife and the
mailman right so he was that wasn't me
no no it was me this is a white dude
that one was like re you know very oh
yeah he read a lot of books he rolled
his own cigarettes he wore like nerdy
glasses before they were cool in 1988
when I was in that and the morning shift
in that library was me Antoine and this
[ __ ] librarian and you know we were
in there from 9:30 to 11:30 and it would
start on politics but then it would end
on murder and how he killed this one and
this one kill this one that you know you
don't just start [ __ ] killing and I'm
saying like this guy had piped somebody
and put him in the hospital but he got
away with it because they went to his
house without a warrant
like the librarian do like he was
[ __ ] always crazy he do you is it
hard to make friends in there because
people did all this [ __ ] no because it
was weird you're in the kid like I
suppose I got you get off the [ __ ]
bus they unshackle you they they give
your sheets and all that [ __ ] you have
whatever you have coming from the other
place you go to your bunk hopefully it's
close to chow but before Chow you got to
go see your [ __ ] counselor and your
counselor has a chitchat with you and
tells you what he expects from you and
what programs you have to be in you do a
8 twice a week and you have to [ __ ]
go to the cycle group for drugs and you
have to go to the other side called
group and they got 15 groups there so
what you do is you sign up for all of
them because they all cut your time see
spend your dang group yeah I went to a
rape group I went to a [ __ ] a victim
group like I got raped I did everything
but he just make up stories no you don't
say no you sit
even the bag you drink the coffee you
eat the cookies and you sit in the back
and wave so Joe you want me to lie to
you tell you at least you didn't have to
make up a story for all these like
cancer survivor'
no no I know you think I'm that chick
from [ __ ] one of those movies no no
no it wasn't cancer survivors you have
to go to these courses if you have
committed these type of crimes and then
we'll give you some type of therapy okay
how was it because I didn't get caught
with the machine gun I didn't get
charged or wasn't supposed to I wasn't
the court didn't make me go in like a
weapon they called it something
aggravated assault class or something
that's have you assaulted somebody if
you mean somebody if now I went to that
class you want that was the first time
my life I had been skinned because
nobody was doing drugs in those days
that gave me that [ __ ] the [ __ ] that you
shuffle methadone no no no the other one
that they call it something like that it
makes you [ __ ] like a like a Zombo so
in those days have you shown any [ __ ]
sign of aggressiveness they put you on
that [ __ ] now they wasn't yes they would
yes they would yes they would then tell
you it was something else and they put
you on that [ __ ] and you sleep all day
you'd only be up for chow and for your
[ __ ] job they had a time just to calm
you down and there was a couple of those
[ __ ] savages in that assault class
whatever this is the first time I've
ever talked about this way I know I have
no words my life what would they talk
about in the classes they would tell
their story and then the counselor would
tell them why they had that like this
won't guy broke somebody's kneecap with
a pipe or something
and he [ __ ] that was scary because he
started telling the story about his mom
when cigarettes out him and she would
tie them up and have sex in front of
them you know like they they get that
deep when you start listening to uh
listen to be an animal that does that to
some
we you and I got into an argument you
pushed me I hurt your feelings I push
you you punched me in the head I kick in
the stomach if we don't talk for two
weeks everybody goes home happy you're
not gonna talk [ __ ] about me you
violated me through always gonna be
brothers it happens what if I pick you
up and throw you off the [ __ ] balcony
yeah what would you think about me that
and you broke a hip that's malicious
there's an explanation why people do
that Lee there's an explanation why
people do that and when you dig a little
deep it's [ __ ] ugly and I didn't know
this I didn't think I I know this [ __ ]
going into that that's why ever since
like I was always an I was always
enthralled with psychology in a way I
just wasn't in another school of
psychology right like I wouldn't mind
taking like the courses that were
required it's a long process
yeah I being anti daughter though but
you know yeah it's too much they break
it down a little bit too much it's a
little bit too Freudian and [ __ ] but you
know when you talk to people like those
guys at a high level they're really
sharp and I had I I don't know something
I know because I know I'm half [ __ ]
[ __ ] myself but I also know when
something may [ __ ] right with
somebody okay so we talking about it
about that therapist know when
something's not right about the assault
class oh the assault class don't take me
off that okay so there was like nothing
it was a scary thing there was a check
like that always stuck out my mind take
teacher it was a chick counselor in that
class she was a smaller black woman
light-skinned very educated she was
sweet but she wouldn't show it because
it would be a sign of weakness on one of
those gorillas we [ __ ] rape her right
in the class though she had a [ __ ] be
firm if you were late don't show up she
was laws women you know and I had
preached I was never late for a class I
was never I was always early for those
things I'm surprised people would open
up like that well have to 5:00 you
required to go to them every week okay
okay eventually no matter what you think
you're going to those things you go home
and you make a predetermined of what
you're gonna say and what you're not
gonna say and then some crazy
[ __ ] goes in there and tells and
breaks down and says my [ __ ]
and her boyfriend ran a train up my
[ __ ] and then picked me out they
smoked crack with my [ __ ] toes and
and you feel so horrible that whatever
happened to you seems minut so after a
while you want to state your case and
you go you know what I'm gonna fall in
tell my story you know you're compelled
to say like I feel like for weeks I told
the kidnapping story and they were all
laughing at me and you know if you
watched the third season on our coast is
it free season yeah if you watch the
third season are close at the end
there's a part where the crazy Colombian
is torturing the the securities expert
and he's telling me you know what that
only link about you that you don't carry
a gun and he goes it's their problem
with me not carrying a gun do you
remember the same leader and he goes
maybe you're scared maybe you'll find
that that you're really an assassin
that's what that teacher said to me
because even like guns or why did they
say that to you because they heard the
whole story and I told the story how I
would've the trunk of the car and pulled
out the [ __ ] gun
and I coulda just ended this so you
didn't lady could have just ended this
like after and I ran again when I went
in there and [ __ ] August I didn't
even dream of getting that deep with it
but by November get on like I said you
go what am I going to these for for 45
minutes every [ __ ] week to sit here
like a deaf mute I gotta get something
out of that and like I said people went
in there and told horrific store
recently about taking her eyes out and
biting people shooting a kid by mistake
you know you have no [ __ ] idea what
do you have Lloyd being my friend
I never broke down on one of those
things but I always left that going
that's how I realized that I wasn't the
criminal that class that class made me
realize that you know what this game
ain't for me this is what's really out
there and if I keep doing what I'm doing
I'm gonna stumble upon this layer of
[ __ ] savages somewhere along the way
not that I never stumbled upon savages
like this before but when you're one of
them you could pass by it but surrounded
by these mammals it was really and léa
that's why I don't know it was a great
experience for me that was it humbling
almost good town it sounded like nothing
you would think you were like mitla best
but telling you almost like you really
kind of a big shot and then you hear all
this stuff like oh listen it made you
feel bad and good in many ways like you
walked out of there less facing people
I'm gonna line nobody you walked out of
there going oh and I thought my life was
bad maybe I'm not gonna call his
grandma's foot and you know I mean there
was just [ __ ] horror stories and I
don't forget oh I didn't forget all of
them like I I can't remember all of them
but I do remember the kid with the
[ __ ] cigarettes and just just
horrible [ __ ] and I thought about him
for one time now you start thinking
about the [ __ ] people right okay and
you start going this guy's 30 years old
this happened to him from the ages of 5
to 9 and he's been walking around with
this inside him for 20 years for 20
years that they they they [ __ ] him in
the ass and put dildos in his ass and
his own parents did this tour and then
it's fear go to his father's house and
his father would make them blow to you
uncle you know you don't have a [ __ ]
idea these kids and they become men
they're carrying this [ __ ] so where the
[ __ ] I think I've ended up their value
is nothing inside you see that they
think it they know it they don't they'll
sit there and tell you they got no value
but they'll go on and kill or be killed
again and don't make it [ __ ] nervous
I went I'm gonna lie the I went to the
rape only two times and that was just to
disturb you I can't imagine it was
disturbing to me the drug one was
hilarious
there were always a [ __ ] pisser there
always a [ __ ] piss of the drug ones
because everybody was a kingpin
nobody was just a [ __ ] regular top of
the lodge you know drug dealer
I had [ __ ] everybody they had [ __ ]
boats their attorney yeah they all got
[ __ ] stories that's the worst one I
went to the alcoholic one that was a
couple of them because I was busy in the
afternoons there was a couple therapy
grosso had a go to and I told the truth
you know I just told them what I knew it
that I thought stand up with nowhere in
my life stand up was nowhere in my life
at that time right not even [ __ ]
closely so it's kind of [ __ ] crazy
yeah not even close like I'm trying to
think back by then I'd gotten on what
was my so-called stage at that time
right yeah I was already getting up on
Thursday lights internal Oviedo stuff
during the movies is [ __ ] yelling
and screaming about two weeks ago I was
on the road and I was thinking about the
guy used to pick on a lot a couple weeks
ago I went to buy a bra and I Pro pad
with my wife very quickly
his wife had him you know I've called me
last week about something and we laughed
for about three minutes about mirrors
what there is the mirrors when you think
when you call the windows mirrors oh I
don't want to distract from the story I
believe in the hall I say what is this
[ __ ] place and there's this
light-skinned sister she's really light
skinned with a thousand freckles on her
and I sat there with her and I really
got a great kick out I gave her a great
reading with Sprint hit me up
I always think about going there saying
hello but I don't want to seem like a
creepy uncle so I just well going down
but I really fell in love with her
because she was cool as [ __ ] but she
reminded me of this dude in prison I was
tight with he was one of those orange
black dudes what he was honours but he
had freckles and he had freckles
everywhere I don't think I've seen
anyone like that
well the basketball player from the
Celtics wouldn't that be y'all remember
him when I was a kid I forget what his
name is in those black dudes they got
freckles they got a bunch of freckles
and [ __ ] well this dude had a bunch of
freckles and he was like orange skin
black anyhow a car is black hair
it was [ __ ] hilarious and he worked
in the kitchen with us okay and he would
always be telling stories about he was a
drug dealer and chicken walk his tongue
- shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up
negro what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you bum three cigarettes and me
yesterday you ain't no [ __ ] drug
dealer did he make a noise or something
why did he call himself Chicken Hawk
did like I don't know I never asked him
I never asked her chicken hard he used
to make me going through the black rooms
and play down below whatever the
president they would [ __ ] hate me but
there was nothing they could do he was
Antwon Spence Spencer Antwon and [ __ ]
aka Chicken Hawk from New Orleans and he
told us one day like that you know when
somebody's telling you a funny routine
like if you watch Bill burr you get
summers in that [ __ ] right and you start
laughing your ass off for Segura Rogan
sometimes you get summers in that [ __ ]
we're in the kitchen one night Lee the
way meaning you sit here like with Becky
or somebody else and they come in here
Nick fort or we're just sitting here
talking but there was like five of us
and we had because we used to they would
cook [ __ ] in the kitchen and then each
of us would smuggle stuff from the
bodega and we'd make a big meal one day
a week all the kitchen important all the
kitchen employers will go to the store
every day even if they have borrowed
money from us they go to the store every
day and they bring back supplies and I'm
Friday we make like a port
gumball like real tiny shrimp with
[ __ ] with imitation crab meat and
then you know he would make like
Louisiana and the kid from New Orleans
Antwone he would make that and then we
make saltine crackers with sardines ooh
oh yeah we'd be throwing Heat [ __ ] on
[ __ ] Fridays living like doctors and
that mother [ __ ] clawing up your toilets
Oh disgusting I was living off those
[ __ ] things but well that was one of
the weirdest because you always hang out
with people and they tell you funny
stories right like the day stories bug
on a vacation or when their kid played
in the third grade or whatever this guy
was telling us a story how he murdered
the guy he was in prison for and we were
in tears on the floor Howard that's how
funny he was you listen to me going Joey
how can somebody tell you about of
murdering in tears so he told you about
the martyr he told us the whole day how
it went down why it went down so he had
already gone through the whole trial he
wasn't yeah we were doing time alright
he had nothing to lose he had nothing to
lose so we're sitting around eating
[ __ ] lunch whatever everybody
everybody else was gone from the
cafeteria you know it's like six of us
just sit there I think me and party this
dude's name was a Jew party a [ __ ]
good-looking white dude from Cali blond
hair the whole [ __ ] thing there was a
troop of those dudes too there was a
dude that looked like Don Henley from
California I was there he was doing
federal time for [ __ ] reefer Oh
important reefer from California to
Colorado and there was another white
dude there and I got a taste of all
three of them were cool the older white
dude used to give me books and [ __ ] to
read very nice he was [ __ ] cool as
[ __ ] but Purdy and me was so tight we
ended up at the same halfway house in
Boulder Oh sh and bam reunion and then
there was another guy that was a car
dealer that was turning
back two miles okay he was turning back
the mouse on the car and he was doing
time his name was Kelly his last name
was Kelly I don't know what his first
name was [ __ ] Zandt on coke fiend
[ __ ] even in prison he was
playin coke snort coke how to avoid them
like the plague
roll back yeah he taught me I knew how
to roll it back but he was a pro at it
and they got caught but he was the guy
that he would be working though he'd be
working the line okay so I would work in
the morning guys okay
my shift was 7:00 a.m. to 9:00 10:00 I
would wash my hands go to my room take a
piss and shoot write to the library
okay and then I wouldn't have to go back
in that talk 112 told about a corner of
the one and then me and the guys would
sit around and talk [ __ ] and one day he
was just like hey so it's always how you
guys ever want to murder the guy right
so this now this white dude the dude was
in jail for turning back miles Lee he
was hilarious he wore glasses he was
goofy but he was a killer he was calling
[ __ ] like he was just running a one-man
operation out of a [ __ ] big time
Chrysler dealership in Lakewood like
this vielen been there for 40 years
family he disgraced it single-handedly
he was snorting coke he was [ __ ] the
receptionist he was [ __ ] customers
wives I mean he was a one-man demolition
crew and he had zero remorse his wife
for coming crying and he [ __ ] tell
her go [ __ ] yourself deal with it I left
her 20 G's he was nuts but the cool
thing about him was that he would be put
he was a dude who put the food out you
know those dudes that put the food out
through the trays caterers no no he was
no [ __ ] caterer he worked in the
kitchen okay his job was to [ __ ] take
the mashed potatoes and put him over the
[ __ ] sternos and then the other thing
over the stern oh so you would put all
like six things vegetable a [ __ ] this
so that I can't you know
our dealership no this is at the [ __ ]
prison
Oh gotcha Jesus Christ what the present
gotcha
when he was in charge of putting out the
food
Oh so as soon as he'd lay out the food
and go up to him I go what's the story
and he go don't do it like he would just
go okay and I would sit in the back and
the black dudes coming and now it's my
color to them don't do it I mean and
that was it don't do it don't do it and
it was me and Kelly I think his name was
Kelly it wasn't Frank that's a different
dude this guy was like Mike or Daniel or
something like that this was a party all
right so back to lunch weary lunch and
were eaten and somebody was talking to
my son and chickenhawk we have his old
tooth he was dressed in white if you
worked the kitchen you got a dress on
white and he had black boots on I never
forget it like it was yesterday and we
were in jail that we doing the jheri
curl
well his jheri curl was all [ __ ] up so
his hand would stick up in the air like
a lunatic and [ __ ] okay
and him just added to his persona and
was sitting there [ __ ] and he and
awesome his town was yeah it was like
that dad killed that [ __ ] and
were like huh and he's like yeah man
you know I'm in front of my
[ __ ] house you know I don't
know what he was talking about but he
just went into Italy just like if he was
saying hey you remember the game last
night he just went into it yeah I just
thought we were sitting there bunch of
us all day drinking you know I never did
a drug in my life you know he was taught
that what made him unique like he didn't
believe in drugs you know what I'm
around if he would tell you when you
moved into that chef's barrack the
kitchen barek ah if you do drugs don't
move into barracks bro because I'm gonna
find out and I'm gonna have you moved
out so he's a drug I'm done you're
writing I don't move in the shaft
there's a little barrack for kitchen up
it wasn't as nice though I so that's why
I live in that barrack and did you
follow the rules you had into drugs in
there okay
I didn't smoke part of it I did add some
of your time they test gently and if
they test you you had a minimum-security
camp you're living like a doctor nobody
says bully okay okay if you really want
you could drink but wait let me get
drunk with a bunch of guys and do what
so I did ask them with the librarian
they crazy librarian I like Christian
dude one day so like fun voltage there
who doesn't what we talked about we're
talking about spent Antwon telling you
so he's telling us the story of how he
was there all day having a great time
barbecue and he went to the front of his
house and there was something going on
things that this is why you gotta be
careful he goes I learned that from that
day on you got to walk away because you
don't know what this other [ __ ]
carrying and something happened I mean
bro he locked us in it was at the
greatest story I had ever heard in my
life at that point and this isn't by
somebody who's braggadocio he was very
quiet he wasn't allowed black guy at all
neither he was the movie theaters he
wouldn't say a word
cuz I have to beat him to get a word I
don't watch a football as [ __ ] he loved
to laugh he was about 6 foot 2 to 25
yeah like for kids he made a lot of
money like he wasn't a drug he made a
lot of money he did something like
construction and he believed was a
realtor you could tell he was a sharp
guy if I was 25 he was about 35 I know
he had like one of the best attorneys I
know he it paid a lot for his attorney
to get him out he paid a lot of money as
it cuz I'm a man talking about he got to
make three payments of 50 grand the
first six months or something then for
the
trial he had to pay him together
something like that so I know he had a
white eternity of Jewish summer I forget
what we used to brag about it but yeah
he walked he said he wanted to do it do
pull the gun on us and he goes this is
you know this dumb [ __ ] your
Punk got on me in front of my house you
know he was living like in 1950 there's
a white guy no I think it was a black
guy
you never disrespect the black guy like
that there's some people bro you take a
weapon out in front in their [ __ ]
house you're dead you're dead that's a
[ __ ] the goal of some people is shoot
you don't know when that be in defense
if you come into your house I put my gun
in the [ __ ] trunk before I walk in
yeah so the same thing okay this guy but
he didn't look at it like that he didn't
know you know it's like I don't even
know you
it's like of you not another door right
now y'all might shoot everybody my
[ __ ] in here who's [ __ ] my
wife in here
unlike the dog no it's me you know why
nobody's [ __ ] your wife we're in here
doing a podcast my wife is in these
[ __ ] I'm gonna start shooting
[ __ ] if you know whatever and you go
out there and also you and the [ __ ]
shot or whatever he said he thought they
got to put the gun away I think I told
him get the [ __ ] away from me before I
shoot your black ass and a bunch of this
[ __ ] so he said he just turned around
and walked into his [ __ ] house ooh
that was a mistake that was a mistake he
came right back out with a knife and a
gun move pay he was sonic qube I came
out with a knife and a [ __ ] gun he
just jumped on the front of his house
it's too bad he didn't have the gun on
him because then you gotta just killed
him in self-defense
it was some crazy [ __ ] story man but
having more of us for life it was one of
those stories where you sitting there
and your heads [ __ ] spreading from
the from the story like what the [ __ ] is
here it was really crazy we that was
those cup like I remember
I wasn't proud of going to prison I was
proud of going to prison for one reason
because I got out of the way like by the
time I got sentenced and I digested for
years I was like you know what I'll be
even when I get out of here that's it my
car will start from scratch that's I
mean it's amazing what we tell ourselves
I guess that's what I told myself so I
said [ __ ] it now I get to [ __ ] him I'm
thinking I'm doing four years
your than the attorney told me he was in
a file for reconsideration motion after
120 days and 90 days or something like
that okay all right that's what the
[ __ ] dude told me so i sat there it's
August 15th and I'm like okay what 220
days that's September October November
December ooh that's a bad time of the
year to be filed a motion that's like
come on the ball money from some of the
other 15 euros a Christmas is a week
away son nobody wants to work on the
15th well thank you never occasionally
you got a bad attitude you attorney
right who gets a bad ass you judge and
says come on Rosh Hashanah starts
talking a couple bar mitzvahs come on
open the books for this kid on the
[ __ ] Thursday
you know the 21st or something like that
is it and what would it still do all
right even if I got the grant motion
even if I got the motion grant that I'm
sorry even if I got the motion granted
it was still taking me 30 days to get
premises right is that it do you think
that's where you will learn to be how
focused you are because you can't but
that's the thing I hate the most is
waiting for something I hate that I
always anticipate things like I can't
get myself worked up what would you do
if tomorrow you had to go to court
right Oh a parking ticket at 9:30 in the
morning right you would talk to me at
7:15 we made some [ __ ] racial slurs
at one another we talked about Paula we
talked about the podcast you told me
what he ate last night he's smelling
your next loves like hummus and you told
me you gonna call me at 1:00 when you
coming back from court
what if at four o'clock in the afternoon
when I got a collect call from you in
the county jail and you tell me to call
my attorney
to get them down there but they're
mistaking you for somebody and typical
of that you're gonna do it they they're
charging you with this and this and this
and it is your car you saw the density
and when you pull it when you got it at
the court they showed it to you know
just something obscure you know that
what would you be thinking the first 24
hours late you're missing this you're
missing that your girlfriend's gonna
find that thing you have a little blank
look there's a thousand things on your
mind
that takes two days to process and then
boom you get everything you're gonna
quit the mom on the face the judge will
set the bail that's another mind [ __ ]
okay okay you know and then also and
bail get set
and that's another six hours until you
[ __ ] get released because they gotta
hold you in there for a certain amount
of hours so the state gets a daily pay
for you okay so if you if you're in
there frame house the right gate gets 55
hours a day for you so you get bailed
out 11:00 they'll make you wait till
5:00 and then 501 you're like what the
[ __ ] just happened
yeah I put the money up here ten the
morning we've been waiting on in for six
[ __ ] hours Jesus Christ so now
you get out right right it's worth 50
right now you get out you have a couple
months to process what's going on and if
you're an [ __ ] like me you actually
believe you're not gonna go to prison
even though the guy you paid [ __ ]
$1000 a myth told you that you're gonna
do [ __ ] time whether it's 90 days in
county or 90 day he said 90 days in
prison
then you gotta file a reconsideration
motion and then you'll be out but he
either all you do 90 [ __ ] days and
you didn't think it was gonna happen I
thought I was gonna go this week
the [ __ ] but on August 15th it
took me about six days to process till I
wasn't going oh it's about six days the
process that you're not going anywhere
what that means is that all that [ __ ]
your body gets released you accept that
shitty bed you start watching people's
TV you start making friends because the
first few days you want to talk to
nobody you're a short-term you know be
out of there you have the best attorney
in town you get the [ __ ] out in two
hours and I'm saying you got [ __ ] you
like that see from any Murphy here's my
[ __ ] that yeah I'm getting out of
here bail on thing you got nobody you
make up this [ __ ] by the third day
your own mind starts making them
different scenarios you start calling
people you've met like three years ago
you know and listen I got bail for 50
that mean you just start you know it's
crazy but once you accept it that's a
completely different feel when you know
you're going away you're in you there's
no escape unless you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're only in there for four years so
it took about a week ten days to accept
that and then you accept your fate you
find out where you're going things slow
down you start talking to people you're
giggling at night the black dudes make
you [ __ ] laugh at night you know they
they have apple pie in there you get to
play basketball with waits for an hour
so you're okay you don't talk to nobody
about nothing heavy you keep it light I
get to where they do all the testing
diagnostic diagnostic quickly it's a
diagnostic and I'm already talking to
counselors about what I got to do with
how much time I got
and they're already telling me can you
imagine I'm already prepared to do till
February assignment that maybe March
April you're prepared to do okay and
this lady told me right out she goes
here's your [ __ ] deal she goes
right now as it stands you've got an
18-month sentence then I got a 24 months
a 24 months three years okay two years
okay she goes you did two months in
county and you've already done a month
or something got your way it worked out
I had 18 months left to go
what as soon as I got it I had 18 months
left to go see went from four years 22
months to 18 months so right off the bat
because the time I had done in County
right and the time I was already in
whatever I got four months taken 624
days 18 six months would shut right off
okay so I had 18 months left okay
and she said to me we have another
situation for us to even keep you in
here you have to be a 1-point you have
minus one but she goes we have to send
you right to a halfway house by law we
gonna send you right to a halfway house
but you have another problem you're
eligible for a halfway house but you
don't get to a halfway house do you 16
months away from this sense so in two
months so she goes what do you want to
do is whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
she goes the more time you spend in here
but she goes I already got a
reconsideration motion so I mean
sometimes next year early next year
you're gonna reconsideration motion both
January 20th the president was getting
sworn in that day what the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with joy but that
is I went he granted me Community
Corrections so everything worked out as
planned but it was still the same thing
I was still gonna end up in the halfway
house one way or another and there was
no way you could spend the rest of your
time in prison and just get out full no
I had to go somewhere I got how to got a
boulder a long month and what fun did he
want to go to I wanted to go to Boulder
I want to be close with my peoples okay
I want to be able to run my little game
but it was uh it was an education that
whole group thing as much as I don't
believe in a Lada it wasn't that type of
psychiatry all right it was people
telling what they did and then we talked
about it for two or three weeks and then
she [ __ ] put a swirl on you and by
that time you'd be broken you'd be
thinking about it she had you thinking
about it and making notes and [ __ ] like
that
[ __ ] that's amazing that she had that
powerful people you know I remember
talking to her about what I had done in
the machine gun and she told me she
knows what went on with you and I told
that I've lost my mom with this and this
and your dad and my dad you know and she
was like wow no and I told him of my
stepdad not giving me any money and the
anger I had but I told her the truth I
said yeah I thought about shooting them
and stuff okay
and she goes then this was evident so
she goes thank God nothing bad happened
here she doesn't want to have him you
only until New York went to shoot him he
had to a gun fight with him and you
killed him but he shot you in the white
on the way down or something she does
this worked out pretty good
and it was true after whatever went down
with the gun and the gun pointing his
[ __ ] that was enough of mailing in my
don't mind he that was enough of a meant
that's good
I don't want to be around this [ __ ] ever
again after that was Jesus Christ I
don't blame you up to that point I
didn't give a [ __ ] I was playing in that
field for about
three years I was walking around Miami
Vice added fuel to the [ __ ] fire
right and added fuel to the fire and
that any cocaine took me over the
[ __ ] edge and that's what happened
for me [ __ ] thinking about all that
[ __ ] I thought I was gonna get away with
some type of [ __ ] Miami Vice machine
gun type deal that's Shane got a [ __ ]
worth anymore
I'm I know you don't believe in like a
lot of universes but even if it was just
like you were gonna one through the
process of going to your car to get
those guns if you did it ten times how
many times do you think you stopped cuz
like it's amazing I'm so happy that you
did but it's like that one that one
decision and there must have been some
time that you could have been angry
enough to go [ __ ] it I think the
realization of going to your car and
taking a gun to shoot somebody after you
just walked out of a place where a guy
was tied up with a machine gun told that
was as real as it got and I tell you
something between you and I the fantasy
side had at the time or whatever was
going through my head or the pain and
the addiction the host [ __ ] that was
going on with me at the time I had a
little percentage of common sense and
like I told you we spoke about the other
day what you going to have round
that's her different round once you have
that realm over you that you and I'll
never forget when that whole developed
thing went down that I was in the
driveway and I looked around okay I was
making believe I was getting a jacket
and take it off that's what I was doing
I was taking the jacket off and I put in
a back seat and I was just looking
around and there was no cars in no
driveway
well that's they everybody had they call
it a garage it was a sunny day it was
October 18th it was a so November 18th
of them something like that
it was a sunny day it was this the the
the leaves were coming down type day you
know it was like one of those type
solved with the 63 degree with the Sun
out time things matter well I mean I
don't forget I looked around and I go
you know what if I shout these guys and
nobody would ever know three bullets
nobody would know all I have to do is
sit tight for 10 minutes wipe down the
[ __ ] door knobs and just get the [ __ ]
and praying to God nobody comes out of
the house and you're not that stupid
you're like one of the odds of that
happening there's always some old ladies
looking out a [ __ ] window
pure wise Lord on a lot o either the
taste of four days turn them and what
some white car
how do you know because you know my
husband drove the same one we're looking
for a 64 Chevy empower some [ __ ]
stupid hood and who knows but something
like that came through my mind
i cabled I was happy I was in that house
no more I got gonna call that [ __ ]
left and I don't remember correctly but
I already had the coke gun like I had a
piece of coke at the house okay and
that's all I gave a [ __ ] at that time so
at the end look who won
Nicky Skinner Jim nunya Elliott Smith
bad [ __ ]
Caleb Ferg say Zhou Santana Billy
Hosanna Tony BBF three Jarvis my no
Charlie H and my main man Tony capicola
always thrown [ __ ] he you know I love
you [ __ ] with all my heart but
listen man like I was talking to my wife
today we sit in the kitchen and I
explained to her today that that little
thing that I had growing up then always
paying attention I've always had that
guys and it's a blessing I'm not gonna
lie to you I think that uh if I have
anything good go for
me it was always my Eisley honest to god
honest to god I love that [ __ ] I live
for that [ __ ] you know when I Drive back
from the store I can make a ride and get
I always drive past your house and make
a rather in your block just to check on
you
thank you I don't beep because I'm a
gentleman I don't act like a [ __ ] I
have a ball anymore 20 years ago or I
would have beep down further and called
you at the same time than left made you
come down to the left told you had some
KFC for you and Lulu so no no no no
every that I loved all that [ __ ] I loved
watching you know I sit on my porch
sometimes and I see who would watch
somebody breaking into my house there's
only one [ __ ] window it's terrible
you know all the other windows are
covered so you could be shoot you know
it's just a shame so I was telling my
wife thank God we got that [ __ ] ring
yeah we got the other ring ring with the
[ __ ] the whole light the taping and
the whole new cameras now you need 10
[ __ ] things then and then I listen
man I'm listening 9/11 the world changed
and on Monday the world changes again
the world really changed the gun they
hit us where we always thought would
never happen we always thought if they
had lost Vegas do it's gonna be a
complete different way man you know
mayweather would have a big UFC once the
Raiders got there you know I mean
there's something going on in Vegas
every goddamn week but if this was
[ __ ] inaudible right I think we're
gonna see metal detectors and I for one
don't care about that at all I mean it's
gonna take a while to get through I feel
that suck listen guys
every time I'm flying back on a Sunday
or I'm leaving there by the time I get
to the security point
if I tell you something honestly I
always think I'm gonna die every time I
put my luggage I'll have security thing
that will sleep apnoea pouch right I
think yeah I think right there I'm gonna
hear Viva Isis and something lost like
just like [ __ ] some guys with a
pokemen eight out of his [ __ ] jacket
there I go getting hit by a chair or so
or some dudes cane or something like
that right I swear to god I'm my own way
even at Burbank Airport I could be by
myself and as soon as I'm walking out
I'm expectedly got to say Viva or
whatever the [ __ ] Isis and there I go
push and that's it 22 wounded Burbank
Airport disgusting comedian Joey Diaz
found this [ __ ] fat little feet
hanging off his fungi toe still lives
forever
oh but every time I'm [ __ ] fine I
think I'm gonna [ __ ] get Iced every
time right there at the airport right at
that [ __ ] TSA gate and if you want me
to lie to you then I'll lie to you but
I'm not alone at the I'm telling you
that this is [ __ ] crazy
that's how scared I am and now I raised
my fear just a little bit more as an
American as a comedian who goes to Vegas
all the time yeah well you know I mean
this is part of it this is part of it
this is part of the [ __ ] game man I
mean I grew up I grew up we went to
Disney World all the time I was very
lucky you probably would love to take
your daughter there I mean some wedding
is that one gonna happen what are they
gonna hit NFL game one of they gonna
have a baseball game what if somebody
good you know what is that what is the
next thing now it's just gonna be
avoided by automatic weapons it's just
gonna be avoided by metal detectors at
the stadiums oh that's it that's it
you know 20 years ago was the Oklahoma
Obama will need to drive a car or they
leave bombs under the building
bottles in the cars it's a different
level now guys and now you know what
happened what was the one you just
mentioned Edmonton or the cards Rove
yeah
listen well I'm walking now guys listen
if you listen to the church do me a
favor keep that [ __ ] phone in your
pocket there been a favor
ain't nobody funny enough is there's no
important there's nothing as important
as your [ __ ] life
yeah nothing is important in your life
you get to a street corner you put your
[ __ ] phone in your pocket you look
straight ahead it's just like when you
were a kid what would I tell you left
right left
welcome back the kids start man and he
gotta go back to [ __ ] basics another
life you see something you know again
dirty [ __ ] bags well holy banks did
you say I think it was 30 outlaw Google
30 bags upstairs inside and out not one
camera caught that three days he got
there on the [ __ ] Thursday he went
buff [ __ ] bananas on Sunday so over
three days he carried 30 bags up and
down and nobody caught this pestilent
this looks suspicious come on guys we're
not paying attention man our heads are
[ __ ] ass and if we don't have the
phone ahead we're taking about a [ __ ]
dumb stupid what's that binge-watch
we're gonna do over the weekend it's bad
and that's enough a little as a logical
American like what wait a second I just
won't go out ten what the [ __ ] don't
what are you gonna do living Cambodia
for the rest of your [ __ ] life you
gotta you gotta go on you got to stand
for something I feel terrible I feel
terrible the last [ __ ] three days and
I don't know anybody I don't I just
dream of it's unimaginable thinking of
being there close your eyes for a second
and think of it being at any outdoor
concert anything it could be anything
you know Ozzy fest [ __ ] whatever this
the did the eighth one oh and he outdoor
festival
you imagine this guy's like I told you
guys earlier you never dreamed 20 years
ago that there was going to be medical
marijuana and some day you walk into a
store and talk to people well now it's
unimaginable that you know people
getting shot out of a [ __ ] beautiful
hotel in lost a Las Vegas window so the
bright [ __ ] side let me tell
you what's crack-a-lackin' Tampa I'll be
slinging dick next week at the Tampa
improv Thursday Friday Saturday and then
the following week at on Broadway in
Lexington Kentucky I'll be over there
with the [ __ ] Wildcats they got
two Cuban restaurants over there and
[ __ ] Lexington and that's how we do
it I'm happy you guys listen to Monday's
podcast with Nick when we discuss the
Yankees and I hope you guys watch me
when I tweeted his periscopes he's a
[ __ ] lunatic let me tell you
something if he got it together and put
a service together for April May June
July August for baseball
I would pay $5.00 a month a month to
watch him twice a week go crazy he's
that funny he's that [ __ ] and he's
knowledgeable as [ __ ] about baseball
I've seen some of his footage on YouTube
of him doing MLB tonight the [ __ ] like
that
he knows the [ __ ] game I just don't
know the game so I can't if I knew the
[ __ ] game of baseball this would I
would love to go back and forth with him
about baseball where was he 35 [ __ ]
years ago
all I knew everything about baseball a
new referendum won pies I swear to God I
knew the [ __ ] umpires
Goodley for the major league for the
major league he's describing league for
the Boston Red Sox because that's why I
watched religiously right and for the
National League I would watch the Mets
but then I started watch them for the
playoffs I mean I started your
succession when I was five right so I
started watching other things I started
watching the up byes who will the
umpires for the [ __ ] there when my
team loses and you put them a look on
him or something put themselves I'd
watch you thinking [ __ ] this I'm not
gonna watch this game because this
[ __ ] is behind the plate we're
gonna die a slope that there's an NFL
rough that has that right now people a
time with like Donaghy or something yeah
hey hey I think you make himself but the
anok is amazing it's kind of [ __ ]
crazy that uh that uh you know what the
[ __ ] I was gonna say
the ref will retama Nick Thanks
no it's it's it's crazy how
knowledgeable he is and he'll take you
all the way back he'll take you to them
series batting averages rotation the
bullpen hmm
it's just [ __ ] amazing I long holds
all that knowledge but anyway let me
talk to you some real quick and I'll get
you out of your [ __ ] windy go [ __ ]
jump up and down and go have a great
weekend
but don't forget next week Tampa improv
but the most important thing is I'm
happy [ __ ] around here you're
listening and your [ __ ] family is
showing up at the [ __ ] this shows some
guy gave me a container of [ __ ] weed
and four pushes the other day I got a
bag of mushrooms I hug bunch of [ __ ] and
Pittsburgh don't [ __ ] around
Jenner's sure stop being so generous I
keep forgetting to bring the mushrooms
for you thank you up again let's try to
clean them for you thank you and
therefore I ask them what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna do something Austrian okay
I'm gonna bring nice chocolate not THC
toads today I got a bonus come back to
you you could have they have cookies and
cream no no no they have cookies and
cream no homie it's my favorite play all
listen to me they have vanilla ice cream
with an ice cream cake mm-hmm
200 milligram THC boss the only thing I
didn't like about them is too big of a
ball it's got too much chocolate
Fanta but they say it's like a French
chocolate very fun and very refined so I
may bring it for you for [ __ ] Monday
that's podcast a Sunday night spot guess
one of the [ __ ] we decide to do so
you're looking good soldier look at
you're trying then get the little spots
to light whatever it is working out I'll
tell this new Bloods good like I said I
watched that [ __ ] Yankee game last
night why once woman with my daughter
well I had on because I for some reason
I'm MLB
what I'm gonna [ __ ] serious in the car
so we're screening nothing and by the
time I was making the turn there was
three three maybe a summer it was tied
up right I don't know
it was but I knew the Yankees didn't
stay losing for long was four three
something [ __ ] crazy that I did some
[ __ ] and we we ate dinner we talked
homework and then I went back and I Chi
said there were like eight to four or
something it was kind of nice
I watched baseball for the first time
you know I didn't bet it did I bet it
but no I didn't [ __ ] bet it but if I
would let me tell you something all
right
it's baseball playoffs then you get the
World Series
not to mention right now that's it what
week is it yeah week for five weeks I've
is coming up that means the soft lines
and whatever is gonna happen already
happen you got September little way
professionals no only amateurs gamble
and [ __ ] September October is when it
starts because guess what else is coming
down the pipe BAM
hoops the NB [ __ ] a right and
why well let me ask you a question you
sit there you read the papers you do a
bunch of things you do all this
analytical stuff and let's save you you
worked hard to have a winner and what
are you gonna do what good is having a
winner is not having somebody reliable
to put your bet in with that's why I
always tell people to go to my bookie
dot AG my bookie has been in business
for years their rep is rock-solid I
think it was Lee and a different friend
of mine did business with them listen
they do 100 percent cash bonuses so off
the bat you're making money for doing
nothing and they have two fastest
payouts seriously just two business days
you know who's gonna win Yeah right
that's great you did all the work
lay down the cash and win big today I
would recommend the service to my
listeners that have been good to me if
you're gonna pluck and put some action
in this weekend my bookie dot AG that's
why I'm urging you to make your way to
my bookie you know why you win they pay
you collect somebody sukul I mean and
there you have it they have in game live
betting the most rewarding player perks
in the business and an all-new
you ready for this one mobile site that
makes wagering undergo a [ __ ] breeze
BAM you got a sudden urge to the winner
yardstick it to go to my bookie dot AG
now let me tell you what I'm gonna do
for you right cuz you know I love you
[ __ ] I want you to make money i
way to have money for the holidays is
the time of year you put away yardstick
everywhere you have one game you lay
everything you got on that [ __ ]
you believe in that [ __ ] if you
do that 11 times you're gonna be seven
and four that means you're gonna be wife
seven net [ __ ] winners so if you've
been out to modular week uh means 14
hours ban there you don't want the
Christmas they got a [ __ ] kiss your
feet you following st. if you want to
make a little dough and gamble and get
paid with no drama here you go go to my
bookie right join now in my book e dot
AG will match your deposit with up to a
hundred percent bonus of your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars are you
ready did you hear what I just said to
you join none my bookie will match your
deposit well up to one a percent bonus
of your first deposit of up to $1,000
use promo code Church CH you are CH to
activate the offer visit my bookie AG
use promo code Church today
you play you win you get paid alright
visit my bookie capital and capital B
dot capital a GTA use promo code Church
I know a lot of you [ __ ] Joe is
a lowercase uppercase I don't know it's
a big M and a big beat and a big a and a
big G you play you win you get fake
talks up this beautiful there you go
you're ready to rock listen to me is
that time of the year
holidays are coming you want to be nice
Halloween right then you have the dough
pilgrim then you got a little what
what's it what's it what's a Jewish
holiday over
December Hanukkah Hanukkah then you got
close time
then you got no years you want to be
sharp from head to toe you want to feel
good right you want to look good in your
under way and you want to be comfortable
right you want no drama you don't want
something tight hates on your [ __ ]
stomach a nutsack
you got to pull it out when you're
sitting there trying to enjoy your
lasagna but that perfect is hard but
don't sacrifice style or comfort check
out me on these calm and find the best
pair underwear in the world me and these
will be the most comfortable pair under
way your ever own made from a
sustainable source natural soft fabric
that is three times you ready three
times softer than cotton you know who's
gonna vouch for them me I live off
[ __ ] me of this ultimate feel good on
these for when you wanna feel naked but
not be naked for fellas me on these
diamonds seam pouch cradles your jewels
and gives the stuff supported leads
without feeling too tight
like I said nothing gets caught up in a
nut sack ladies all of the soft
eco-friendly fabric so soft and
touchable 100% money-back guarantee they
guarantee you'll love you on these or
your money back
listen right now me and these is a
exclusive offer for you savages because
I love you you get 20% off your first
pair and you ready free shipping right
to your door and me and these are so
sure you'll love the underwear don't
even offer on the percent satisfaction
guarantee
you order a pair if you don't love the
first pant boom you got a full refund no
questions asked
listen don't be sending underwear back
with skid marks there's a head down line
one one that soft assault in some states
listen is a no-brainer
try 20% off free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee what the hell are
you waiting for
to get you 20% off free shipping and a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
tea and get the best and softest
underwear you'll ever own go to me on
these comm slash Joey again that's me on
this comm slash Joey there's a limited
time offer so listen I'm telling you
right now you want to look sharp don't
keep me what are you waiting for
start wearing the best underwear in your
life it changed my life I want to do
Jitsu every time I go it's time to let
me have these change your life go to me
and these come / Joey right now I want
to thank my main man Lisa at I want to
thank my man Nick Turturro and I want to
thank you [ __ ] Bobby sheryn.low
Lingus you know there's a bunch D in
Colorado there's a bunch you [ __ ]
savages Leon you know I love you Cleo
ooh spooky still in charge of the
[ __ ] bee's nest you know saying you
[ __ ] around with Lukey next thing you
know you get stung by 92 [ __ ] bees
and [ __ ] anyway have a great weekend and
let me tell you son Italy listen we had
a rough couple of months [ __ ] you
Katrina's cousin Maria the other one
Waldo Rico Houston [ __ ] Florida
listen there's been tough up to now the
earthquake in Mexico
you know the White House whoever the
[ __ ] is going on but it don't matter
they want to shoot it's time for us to
[ __ ] this shoot [ __ ]
they want to get down and dirty don't
forget who the [ __ ] we are you
understand me what a baddest
[ __ ] out there you send the
message to that [ __ ] North Korean
he's gonna be sniffing my dick and
suckin my [ __ ]
that's the focus we'll go to North Korea
in like a year it's going to be an
island it's going to glow in the dark
you know life is what Americans
[ __ ] will the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with stop with the gun
control they're selling more guns than
ever the last three days stop with the
[ __ ] whitey
stop with the Russians on Facebook I
don't give a [ __ ] worry about yourself
keep your eyes open and get the [ __ ] on
snapchat and [ __ ] Twitter [ __ ] stay
black